[Applause]
major chaos in canada as petty tyrant
justice trudeau makes good on his
promise to crack down on the freedom
truckers a massive police presence
arresting and tussling with protesters
on the streets of ottawa after taking
two of their leaders into custody some
truckers saying they're ready to leave
with honor but officials apparently
aren't letting them go and are
impounding their vehicles and as we've
been telling you the protesters are not
the only ones getting harassed a cafe
owner who got doxxed after donating to
the cause giving an emotional interview
to our very own jesse waterfowl
i gave a donation to fill a gas tank of
someone so they didn't have to sleep in
-30 in the cold that night and i think
that decision speaks to my humanity
and not to political beliefs someone
draped a large bed sheet
over our sign
i'm sorry it's been it's been a tough
few days and i think
you know and the sign read tammy
supports terrorists
okay jesse you spoke with her i mean you
know this woman gave a what many would
consider a minor donation and she's
being punished for it socially
ostracized criticized and being called a
terrorist she's not a political person
she said she was worried because it was
minus 30 degrees outside so she gave the
donation so truckers could buy gas and
buy food and the next thing you know
she's had her whole life turned upside
down they've vandalized her place
they've called her all sorts of names
and they've called her a nazi
and it's broken her heart and it's a sad
thing to see because she just wanted
everybody to come together and show
respect for each other and she thought
this could have been handled much
differently and she was pleading for the
prime minister
to just kind of do
what leaders do and bring everybody
together and stop dividing everybody and
ultimately the mandates are the most
divisive thing we've seen it in here in
this country now up there they are
divisive and you got to get rid of them
he should have had a maple syrup summit
he should have brought everybody
together how easy would it been for him
to say you know what guys we're going to
pause the mandate
for 14 days let's get together you guys
leave open the bridge let's sit down
have a little dinner maybe some waffles
and then we'll straighten everything out
at least it would have gotten people off
the edge a little bit but he didn't do
that he went full mao on him and and now
look what we have we have a whole
country of people at each other's
throats and where's bieber
he's the most famous canadian out there
he hasn't said a word about this well
you know greg as we talked about
yesterday you've got what everybody's
asking you've got justin
justin trudeau who says that the the
country admires most is china and he
himself is acting like a dictator all he
had to do was start talking with these
truckers in the beginning but instead he
calls the jewish member of parliament
the conservative but you know she stands
with the uh flag waving the swastika
people and now the canadians are doing
the same thing to someone who wants to
contribute i mean can trudeau get this
back or is he just is his legacy going
to be one of a tyrant well if this
canadian breck girl spent half the time
on communicating with the truckers that
he does on his hair this would have been
fixed he should not be prime minister he
should be a wedding dj at a midsize
hotel in niagara falls that's where he
belongs does the media have such a
severe head injury that they don't see
how comical this contrast is when people
were burning down cities in 2020 leaders
were saying give them space and here
they're saying oh my god these people
are honking their horns slash their
tires take their gas take their kids
take their pets arrest them it's an
interesting contrast but if you want to
see who the good guys are this is what i
do when i'm not sure because i do think
that like wait you're not sure about
what no i am a breaking news alert i'm a
contemplative guy but like i want to
make sure that the truckers are
respectful and they're law abiding and
that they're good people and so far they
have been but you want to look at on
who's on what's side right so i'm
looking like who supports the truckers
and who don't well the people who
support the truckers elon musk who just
gave billions to fight poverty jordan
peterson an amazing canadian philosopher
uh reason magazine nick gillespie that
means libertarians are behind him you
got you've got prominent liberals like
glenn greenwald i could go on with the
people that support the truckers just by
going on twitter you can see who then
you look at the other side all it is is
the dying legacy media the dying
cacklers of cnn they're the elitists at
the washington post they are so detached
from the from this class of people it's
so easy for them to call them rubes but
i look at the other side and i go i want
to be with those people i i mean elon
musk's smartest guy in america yeah that
guy's with the truckers count me in you
think well you know what leslie
he's the smartest guy on the planet the
the truth is leslie that there are now a
hundred checkpoints there are a hundred
checkpoints it's almost like east berlin
and they're telling these truckers if
you have an animal and we arrest you you
may never see the animal again and we're
going to call in canadian child
protective services if you have children
with you your kids are going to be taken
into custody i mean you've got to admit
that this is so beyond the pale of a
peaceful demonstration that is objecting
to a year and a half of being locked
down and you know they're over the top
here wouldn't you say
i would say let's look at the people of
canada and specific specifically of
ottawa and what are they saying if you
look at the polls they're not with the
freedom convoy or elon musk if you look
at the polls they're with the vaccine
mandate and if you look at harassment
there is a family that had a uh rainbow
flag at their home and they were
harassed
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
there were homeless people and people
working at a homeless shelter that were
harassed in addition
mean they're all that are you talking
about
there are individuals in this community
who've had to close their businesses and
it's hurt them economically what about
what they fear for their care they fear
for their security so what about what
about what happened in the united states
justin trudeau and the police who met
with the organizers of this movement
originally is just who is his
responsibility to these freedom convoy
truckers or the people
let me ask you a question leslie leslie
the problem is and i said this yesterday
i said parliament has to vote on this
this emergencies uh power act they
punish and and they punt it absolutely
they don't want to vote on it because
they are with the truckers so you can
tell me that the canadians want you know
what are supporting trudeau this guy is
out of his mind i don't agree they're
with the truckers and i agree that they
should have punted and the reason is
this is not world war ii okay and that's
and that's really if you look at the
situation in the scenario what this is
we're gonna have to liberate canada
so we saw the rise of fascism in world
war ii and that's exactly what this is
justin trudeau has turned ottawa and
canada into a fascist state when you
have people who are forcibly being
pulled from their lines arrested having
their
vehicles confiscated so they can't work
having their bank accounts frozen so
they can't spend money they can't pay
their bills uh what what is the one
thing we heard when we were having this
massive supply chain issue where people
couldn't get any supplies into local
drug stores or walgreens uh that we need
more truckers we need them it's tough
jobs
by the way yeah this convoy has affected
the supply chain on both sides of the
border
and maybe if the prime minister had
acted rationally and in good faith like
jesse's recommendation is actually the
best one i've heard suspend the mandates
for two weeks
hammer everything out and then once you
have an agreement uh then commerce it
will be free-flowing uh not only from
the moment you actually sit down but
until there is a resolution justin
trudeau is an embarrassment to the
northern hemisphere and he should be
kicked out of and to all those people
who add to their eyebrows because his
are falling off all the time but what do
you think about the fact that he just
disappeared he wouldn't even talk to
them well a couple of things think think
about our nation i i know we're a
greater nation than canada sorry
canadians
but would a president i don't care if
they're a democrat or republican would a
president sit down he would people
someone he would send someone right
in the head yes he did the head of the
police sat down with the organizers the
head of the police yes
not a representative of justin trudeau
that's right and he quit but i don't
think that i don't think the prime
minister of canada any more than
president should be sitting down
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else